[Musique]
pour moi c'est une saute face à face à
moi-même ils sont des monologues appuyé
creuser et est aussi un travail très
très profond sur l'interprétation même
parce qu'on est
je suis face à part moi même comme
interprète face à roko le wef
et c'était doublement mais même dans un
état assez particulier
[Musique]
prat en 2002 centre chorégraphique
national d'orléans josef nadj qui le
dirige depuis 1995 se met en scène seul
pour une plongée dans cette culture
hongroise qui l'emmener dans ses valises
jusqu en val de loire à orléans j'ai
décidé de vivre ici c'était pour moi
évident que je ne resterai pas à paris
je voulais pas faire des allers retours
mais d'être sur le lieu de mon travail
j'ai mis deux taules chercher de la
glisse avec la avec la vie hein c'est
pas évident si on n'est pas né ici je
trouve que pour que les gens venus
d'ailleurs
il faut de temps il faut il faut
chercher
la prise que j'essayais évidemment et et
que je trouvais à gauche à droite c'est
le cellulaire historique qui est kim qui
m'enchante jusqu'aujourd'hui donc là
quelques quelques endroits magiques qui
sont sous la terre donc à vrai dire
c'est les cryptes que que que j'adore
saint-aignan le petit chapiteau lohman
sais je suis fan des vins de cette
période
et voilà ce sont les images le plus fort
c'est avec avec ces images là que je
partais au relais on nage en agité
furieusement les planches dès 1988 avec
cette peau de rhinocéros dont il reste
cette vieille vidéo aussi rayé que le
spectacle fut déjanté en 88 nadj
arrivait tout droit d'une scène très
très effervescente la scène artistique
parisienne
c'était le début des années 80
la connaissance de la danse beaucoup de
chorégraphes qui ont marqué la danse
française ont débuté ces années là donc
on a partagé cette aventure dans des
cours la gauche à doite et dont des
compagnies donc à l'époque plusieurs
chorégraphes et interprètes comme celle
menée par exemple avec qui j'ai dansé
chez françois déry donc c'est où on
allait voir les autres dans des studios
de livres pas possible donc c'était
vraiment différent en 1990 pour comedia
tempio l'art du mime tels que son
expressivité étaient utilisés par les
acteurs du cinéma muet du burlesque
représente le corps le coeur du style
nadj
[Musique]
effectivement le mime et elle le début
la boue d'appel même j'ai commencé dont
j'ai ajouté quelques couches à paris
mais très vite j'ai tourné vers la danse
contemporaine
carolyn carlson a dit de josef nadj
qu'il était l'un des artistes les plus
intéressants de cette danse
contemporaine entre guillemets
précisément parce qu'il s'est affranchi
de ses cadres le ses codes aussi nouveau
fusse-t-il
[Musique]
ils ont que dès le départ je me suis
plus se référer aux arts plastiques et
la musique et à la littérature que
proprement dite à l'art chorégraphique
je me suis inspiré de ce domaine là et
j'ai essayé de transposer ces mets
vision en dessous vers la scène et ça me
convenait
mais ça m'a facilité aussi la tâche
n'est pas être sous l'influencé des
autres chorégraphes ou metteurs en scène
[Musique]
la littérature ce fut buchner michaud
borgès entre autres et kafka bien sûr si
on les prend les premières pièces et
qu'il était vraiment le
le milieu d'où je viens
natal mais mes premiers souvenirs tels
âgées au fur et à mesure je crois que je
rajouter je commence à puiser dans ma
propre bibliothèque crise en plus que
j'ai emporté avec moi
que j'ai enrichi au fur et à mesure avec
les années que je passe ici
[Musique]
en 1999 c'est au tour de kafka que
tourner le chorégraphe dans les
veilleurs de manière plus éclatante que
jamais sont mises en lumière les liens
que kafka tissé de lettre en lettre avec
l'éternel autres le féminin
[Musique]
oh
woyzeck d'après l'oeuvre inachevée du
dramaturge du chemin et à ce jour
l'oeuvre la plus jouée de nage avec plus
de 200 représentations à travers le
monde
woyzeck l'histoire d'un soldat devenu
criminel par la faute d'un système
auquel il ne peut échapper une tragédie
en écho de la guerre fratricide qui
déchirait alors la yougoslavie des
années 90 bon il ya quelques petites
aventures des trois autres à gauche à
droite qu'on avec le cirque ou avec vos
obsèques où j'ai tenté de la prochaine
dramatique
sinon le jeu reste fidèle à à cette
sorte de la pole avec les écrivains que
je sais de d'apporter montréal une sorte
de dialogue avec leurs oeuvres sont
cherché à illustrer à adapter une pièce
pour qu'aucun dit claude m donc j'ai
écrit des choses avec ma compagne mon
oncle et notre propre matière et on fait
la mesure effectivement on ont bâti un
jeu télé pas un style mais mes montagnes
de motifs qui kinky king dont lequel on
se sent bien
en 2006 asobu inspirée de l'oeuvre
d'henri michaux relie nadj à la culture
orientale et c'est décidément le voyage
d'une culture à l'autre qui porte toute
son oeuvre
mais c'est le japon qui s'imposait saleh
je savais pas combien de fois j'ai aimé
mon seigner et ont saboté à une voilà
une collaboration que que voilà le lasso
bonnes raisons
[Musique]
on essaie de construire une sorte de
tribu imaginaire dans le sens de mes
shows et guéret elle notre propre sens
qu on a mélangé non des êtres différents
et on essaie de prouver qu'on peut
les gens puissent se mélanger on a
beaucoup de choses à dire la source
fondements mêmes de
imaginaire
et comme le japon ou de certains de pays
de l'est et les autres décident de
france ça fonctionne ça c'est le foot
[Musique]
dans l'oeuvre de michao papillonne les
esprits si présent dans l'imaginaire
japonais les esprits qui hantent
l'oeuvre de l'écrivain depuis la mort
accidentelle de sa femme asobu où le
drame de la séparation des corps du
désir de retrouvailles des armes
bush
oh
où
mme beauchamp
après avoir fait triompher sa troupe
orléanaise aux quatre coins du monde
dont le festival d'avignon après avoir
fait oeuvre pédagogique avec des lycéens
et des apprentis de sa ville d'adoption
après avoir créé chaque année depuis 30
ans une oeuvre nouvelle
josef nadj s'en va il retourne aux
sources de son histoire en france à la
scène artistique parisienne
je vais tourner ma part et je le deviens
compagnie des pilotes
et voilà j'ai continué à faire de
performance heurtaux est un peu un peu
plus d'un visionnaire mais quand vous
dites performances vous en exclu et donc
les la chorégraphie est ce qu'on appelle
la danse contemporaine ou non mais je le
transforme en neuf jeux même malaxe un
peu
et je me travaillait beaucoup seul
maintenant il y aura une période dont
sept côté d'être interprète que j'ai
toujours cultivé en groupe ou en solo
là je vais mettre un peu plus d'accent
et on s'associant à mon travail et
visuels de plus en plus
et c'est à orléans que ce tournant dans
l'oeuvre de joseph nadj aura pris corps
par un hommage déployé en plusieurs
lieux
la ville y aura donné l'occasion de
montrer une autre facette de son art la
photographie
[Musique]
la photographie voici comment cet
archéologue créatif en a retrouvé les
prémices de la technique née au début du
19e siècle avec les siens de type assis
nommé parce qu'il reproduisait la
réalité en imprimant d'un bleu cyan tout
ce qu'on voit là ce sont les herbes de
mon désert pour ce que je trouvais que
j'ai cueilli bords de la loire à bord de
chemin fer c'était une histoire pendant
une année à fond la caisse joue la nuit
avec cet herbier dans ses bagages
nadj emporte un peu avec lui des
paysages du val de loire
les orléanais e voit s'estomper les
paysages que nadj leur avait offert
c'est pas plus mal non plus pauvres pour
les hauts de l'année 2
de changer de paysage deux de mes
paysages
[Applaudissements]